let me pull up this story we got from
timcast.com house passes bill to protect
family members of scotus justices 27
democrats voted against it so of course
of course you guys have heard they're
protesting in front of kavanaugh's house
this is a continuation of that story
they decide to protest in front of just
justice's homes it's illegal to do so an
activist organization publishes
information showing people how to get to
these homes which should i'm assuming is
also illegal the federal government says
nothing they're not going to they're not
going to intervene and then genticky
comes out and says well we certainly
encourage this
they're still defending it a dude shows
up to kill kavanaugh they they say okay
oh you're gonna arrest that guy and now
people are still protesting i watch
these videos
of people marching in front of the homes
of kavanaugh and there's statements
coming from the neighbors the neighbors
said after what happened especially we
don't know who these people are we don't
know what's going to happen and we're
supposed to just live this way
no they should be arrested
i could not imagine that i want you all
to imagine this like remember what
happened to tucker carlson they went to
his house were banging on his door and
his wife had to hide in the pantry now
they want to take your guns away yo when
they've got people burning down your
businesses coming to your home and
threatening you and it's happened that
they've gone to people's houses on
numerous occasions and now they're
saying take away their guns red flag
laws let me tell you something you can't
even call the police tim because you've
got to wait outside for 40 minutes
sure sure but but in wisconsin
there was a group of black lives matter
activists
they thought some girls had been
kidnapped they showed up to this house
where they thought the kidnapping
happened and they set fire to it
someone the fire got put out by i think
emergency services they set fire to it
again
this same group of people went in front
of another guy's home because apparently
had an altercation with a neighbor they
called him racist so you've got these
same people everybody knows they were
involved in arson someone was
and so he brandishes a shotgun through
his window the police come and arrest
him
now look
people outside in front of your home he
felt threatened
there's there's an argument about
whether or not he should have brandished
a weapon i mean he's in his own home and
he's making a warning until they said
you can't point a weapon at people but
then it's a question of if these are
people who have set fire to a house and
they're in front of your home
and you're defending yourself like how
would you like imagine this someone's
coming to your property with violent
intentions and you're like i can't point
my weapon at them until after they
attack you so again i don't like the
conflict i don't like that he did it the
point is here's what's gonna happen
you will be in your house
activists and protesters and extremists
will show up and scream at you and then
when you say like back off we are armed
they'll call in a red flag and they'll
say he's a crazy guy with a gun and the
cops will show up and say hand over your
guns
i warned about this in 2018 i said it's
only a matter of time because we were
watching the police not do anything
when one of these group a group of
people will show up to your house and
this is what i'm talking about tucker
carlson here's what'll happen because
i've watched this happen in real time
you guys have probably seen this too
you'll have a group of 50 people they'll
all be standing back and they'll all be
yelling one guy will will like bang on
the glass
then as soon as he does a bunch of other
people start banging on the glass
because someone crossed the line and
they cross with him the glass breaks
then everyone's standing back like oh
the door's open one person will slowly
look in and then someone else will look
in and then the rest of the crowd will
be like oh they're going in
and then they'll start mobbing in we saw
that with those shopping malls during
the riots where it was like i think it
was jake paul or whoever went in and so
what i'm saying is what will happen is
they'll they'll go to someone's house
like tucker carlson they're banging on
the door eventually someone's gonna
break the door it's gonna pop open
then you're gonna see the mob mentality
one is going to peek in another person
is going to step in and then everyone's
going to rush in tim i disagree with you
the the police officers during the blm
riots they did do something they got on
their knees and they put up their fist
and they joined in unison so did the fbi
so did the cia when they were tweeting a
support of black lives matter they were
tweeting in support of marvel movies
like like black panther which somehow
was connected in some kind of weird way
so so seeing this this larger
weaponization of the intelligence
agencies seeing these police officers
within the last two to three years they
exposed themselves they showed exactly
who they are they are agents of the
state the state that is represented by
the people in power that abuse their
power for their own political purposes
for their own financial gain so this is
clear as day and and obviously the same
people that weaponized these
intelligence agencies these police
departments to excuse some of the worst
horrible behavior where dozens of people
died are the same ones that are telling
you trust the police
i'm just following orders exactly in
order yeah yeah which is absolutely
illogical that's what those new york
police officers were saying when they
were literally arresting kids for eating
inside at a restaurant without vex
without the vaccination i'm just
following orders exactly that's not
you know it's horrible i mean you take
you take a look at but that's by design
that's that that gets pushed by this
agenda because you have these
politicians like the story that we're
talking about calling uh civil wars
among us accusing political opponents of
a civil war that's going to be sparked
by them i think chuck schumer
literally called out kavanaugh on a
video and i'm paraphrasing he said
you're going to feel the wrath or you're
getting some pain or the whirlwind
but they they see here's the thing is i
think a lot of people
that may not be politically invested
they don't really look into this stuff
as much as we do we're like obsessed
we're just waiting and waiting and
waiting but the average person is just
watching this and maybe thinking like
this is just happening it's just
happening here we are in american
history where something is happening
it's not by design it's not intentional
there's just these political opponents
that are against each other but people
need to understand
these people know what they're doing
chuck schumer when he says that to the
nation knows who he's talking to he
knows the antifa types he knows the far
left extremists are going to hear that
and take it to the next level but they
already get a pass because all these
crooked da's this crooked law
enforcement the crooked fbi the crooked
you name it all these law enforcement
agencies have been radicalized have been
infiltrated by these globalist uh
organizations where they give them a
pass and don't let them do anything so
at the same time it's like this this
continual subversion where you cannot
trust anything where but but that's
where the constitution comes in i i
appreciate the plea i appreciate what
the police can do they make mistakes
they can screw up big time but at the
end of the day you should have the
ability to defend yourself and your
family period because you could call
9-1-1 and they may not make it in time
you could call 9-1-1 and some
officer like in uvalde decides to call a
stand down for 40 minutes outside of a
school and then all these kids get
slaughtered while they're calling
that's human error that's why you need
the ability to defend yourself but this
is why joe biden is coming out and
saying the second amendment is not
absolute it was not meant to be absolute
it is the perfect storm like i said
they're trying they want they need
something
if it's not the gun grab if it's not roe
v versus wade if it's not climate change
they they're i don't know what do you
guys think what do you guys think is
what they're just really kind of kind of
like luke said is they want you focus on
the culture war while they just destroy
you know
warfare and right now to be honest like
i think inflation is a gift for the gop
if they could take advantage of it if
you guys even look at the polls right
now uh joe biden with hispanics is
record low with hispanics is the lowest
there's that 26 percent um the last poll
i saw with the uh for blacks were at 34
so even the minorities are not
supporting joe biden that's why i know
jamal bowman he's a lot smarter than
what he's saying that's why he has to do
the civil war stuff to do the divide and
conquer but he knows the working class
is struggling he knows he knows that
hispanics and blacks do not approve of
what joe biden is doing because we all
feel the pain at the pump we all feel at
the groceries and even today guys we
were interviewing um we were
interviewing some people at the gas
station just talking to see how it was
affecting their daily lives and one
woman mentioned to us she said hey
everything is up and i'm still getting
paid the same and i think that's how you
know that relates to very memorable some
people are that's part of the goal yeah
i'm not so convinced that there's a
larger agenda like i don't think there's
a group of people who said in by 2050 we
want these things now we do know there
is like the 2030 agenda like there are
literally groups of people like davos
what i mean to say is i think when it
comes to the political powers and the
corporate powers
some of these groups have ideas of what
they want to see the future like but
they're mostly focused on the here and
now and that is what can we do to reduce
consumption joe biden and the democrats
have literally said they want to do this
joe biden has literally said he wants to
transition off fossil fuels so when you
see them take these actions that
transition us away from fossil fuels and
make everything harder and more
expensive i mean they told you they were
going to do it
so there may be literally told the
nation that food shortages are coming
that's right i don't know
here's what i want to clarify
they're probably looking to the future
and saying here's what i want the future
to look like but what i mean is most of
their actions are based off of what can
we what are we doing today so joe biden
today will say what's going to get
people to stop spending money what's
going to get production to go down
there's too much garbage there's too
much pollution these are the
environmentalists the climate change
people have literally told you they're
going to do it and now it's happening i
mean there's a lot of pawns in that
particular game but there's also a lot
of shot callers so i think we should
understand it in both of those different
perspectives because they both play a
very important role here but as far as
what we're seeing i mean they've been
talking about this for a very long time
they name it different things but
essentially when you boil it down it's
about human enslavement it's about
getting rid of human rights it's about
getting rid of people's wealth and
that's exactly what the policies they
have been implementing to a point where
biden's senior advisor gina mccarthy
came out today and said people who
criticize this green transition this
green energy transition needs to be
censored on big tech social media she
advocated for the censorship of this
criticism which she is calling this
green
transfer uh so so again what we're
seeing here just like you were
mentioning it earlier tim is a
transition that they want that they're
implementing there's going to be a lot
of pain and suffering associated with it
but they don't they don't want you
knowing that it's directly caused by
them yeah so i want to make a point here
you guys are sort of talking about
social issues being a distraction and i
disagree that
that's all they are but i would agree
with you that in this particular
situation that's almost certainly the
reason that the left is trying to cling
to every different social issue they can
come into contact with so i believe that
these issues are actually really
significantly important to the long-term
health of our nation but obviously right
now the way they're the reason they're
picking them out is because they're just
looking for something that they can find
to ingratiate themselves with the
american public because people are not
happy with them and
people are going to blame them for
everything that's going wrong under
their watch and so
even with the issues where they would
like to argue they're politically
popular we've talked about this on the
show a couple times before but when it
when it comes to abortion they'll say
something like well you know there are
many pro-choice americans so maybe if we
talk about abortion enough and the fact
that roe might be overturned we could
win some votes but then they take the
most radically far left pro-abortion
position they can and they turn off a
lot of pro-choice people so
they don't even know how to win on
social issues anymore and on top of that
with the economy as horrible as it is
your average person is saying how can i
feed my family if this gets worse well
and the left does not have an answer for
them other than this actually isn't bad
or it's transitory or deal with it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there